Christina Aguilera makes a rare public  appearance for a good cause  whoa this is really like an awesome  right now  [Music]  the popstar stepped out on Thursday  night for a screening of shine to raise  money for Puerto Rico disaster relief  the singer who hasn't been spotted in  public much this year shared this pic on  Instagram writing great evening  benefiting app voices for Puerto Rico  and relief efforts in Puerto Rico it  means everything in the shot  Aguilera posted up with actor Gilbert  Saldivar wearing a floor-length black  dress with red stripes she paired the  look with a black hat long black coat  black studded purse and a bold red lip  I've just had a really amazing time  [Music]